are you guys ready yeah ready to baby
baby
on here we go
may the best baby kill himself take the
bleep snow zippy use your color bleach I
drank it I drank all the bleach baby you
look so gross right now baby yes
am i purple Jen you want to be dad dad
Ken dad you'd be a good dad
if Ken is my dad I would definitely kill
myself do it babies oh god they're
getting worse no you can't have that
this is attack of the tight-end
stop making mark kill himself
oh my god there we go you know what I
wouldn't think of it what are you green
already I don't know
I'm the Hulk [ __ ] him move like my
head's like jerk and discrete oh yeah oh
my god you're possessed yeah hey do you
really use doll talk a lifeless I'm
coming I'm coming
you guys want to have some paint also
with your guests I'll Drive
tab drunk take me to the store can you
get in the car
Oh jack is gonna be the worst father I
know it sweeter a drunkard are you
trying to say something about the Irish
no what are you tagging no I'm not let
me die let's pray Oh baby
Oh No let me go let me go I'm gonna
chase you I'm gonna take my oh baby
[ __ ] come on when I let myself on fire
do that that's exactly my dream Oh God
what the [ __ ] alright listen up you
piece of [ __ ] Oh God if you're not in
bed in five seconds I'm gonna [ __ ] you
kill yourself you piece of [ __ ] I hate
you ya got a bet knock over that think
of the quarter so I can jump on it and
get bed the last one gets a spanking you
have a banana here you go you piece of
[ __ ] I dare you it look like your neck
is completely broken like it oh my god
please son Timmy no no no just a mirror
behind you